the
chicago bears
are four and six they feel so much more
dysfunctional and more in disarray than
yeah one six would yeah how did they win
four games right right and last night it
was not good it got worse when with
three minutes and 24 seconds left down
10 points
out goes mitchell trubisky and in comes
chase daniel so inconspicuous that no
one even noticed that daniel was in the
game it's just hey mitch is gone i don't
know where's chase daniel what the
hell's going on at first the bears
didn't say anything they had no update
and then oh he's got a hip injury which
makes the hip injury even more
suspicious very soon because
wouldn't you make that
announcement right the moment you yank
mitchell trubisky definitely i mean this
whole thing is it's shady in my in my
eyes and i don't mean you know it's
shady it just to me it looks like trying
to help the guy they are they're trying
to help the guy matt nagy's trying to
help himself i think here to agree first
of all the quarterback play in that game
last night was atrocious by both sides
okay so that's the first thing
second thing is yes i don't buy it uh at
its base level right now that there's a
hippie issue i mean i watched mitchell
trubisky
after every play not one point did he
ever grab his hip act like his hip was
tight something was bothering him to me
this is why he was benched and again i'd
like to show both of these plays again
the two third downs at the end of the
game this is the second to last third
down where allen robinson beats jalen
ramsey he's got him beat he throws the
ball
12 yards behind him i don't it's not
even close okay this long conversation
if you're watching on tv where nagi gets
in his ear and covers his conversation
with him for forever here's the last
third down of the game where he just
throws the ball into the dirt doesn't
even try to make anything happen and
after that third down mike i know i can
remember during the game
negi is talking into his headset
covering his mouth again for a long
period of time probably talking to the
coaches going i'm going to take him out
or do something like that now i don't
agree with the decision that late in the
game to make a quarterback change i
think that's still bad i mean trubisky
did lead them down on one score and
trubisky you could argue was the better
quarterback on the field that night now
it wasn't pretty by either one like i
said i mean we had one who they were
managing a 35 million dollar a year
quarterback they were managing them and
afraid to throw the ball on third and
fourth which was unreal third and five
third and one third and two don't they
bring in blake bortles to run the race i
mean i don't know it's unreal just what
went on yesterday in the quarterback
play the first and second pick of the
draft was pitiful both of them but yes i
don't buy the i don't buy the hip thing
i think he didn't trust him in the last
drive of the game and he wouldn't put
chase daniel in because he thought maybe
he could have more success than trubisky
two different drafts though jared goff
was number one overall i know
and it was mitchell trubisky in 2017.
and what makes it more glaring for the
bears is that
patrick mahomes and deshawn watson were
available and they traded up to get
trubisky now it's 33.5 million for jared
oh sorry so it's not 35. so it's not
quite as outlandish but look
we've talked about this before there was
so much criticism of golf coming out of
super bowl 53 the fact that that brandon
cooks was wide open when they ran the
same play that they had run in the first
half yeah popped and he didn't see
brandon cooks the first time they had
the half hour intermission and they
clear i i like to think that in a half
hour half time at the super bowl there
would have been a conversation with
jared goff at some point we're gonna run
this play again and brandon cook is
gonna be wide open he didn't see him in
time right the second time and there's a
lot of criticism about is he truly a
franchise guy there's so much pushback
directly from sean mcvay yeah so many
over-the-top comments about how great
goff is he painted himself into a corner
there's rams themselves
because all and because i've had people
say well surely an agent wouldn't use
that to get caught yes that's what
agents do you you print those comments
off and you laminate perception
sean mcveigh says he's awesome yeah well
and and and if you don't give the guy a
contract and you're saying all these
great things about him then people are
going to think it's all bs yes and it
was all bs
he's doing what he can to prop up a guy
who isn't good enough oddly enough it's
very similar to what jacksonville did
with blake bortles they backed
themselves into a corner and negotiated
against themselves it's almost what
tampa did with him yeah crazyville
it is but it's unbelievable it just it
really is and the quarterback play was
atrocious but yes i don't buy trubisky's
hip injury i don't and jared goff and
the pass offense they need to improve in
la if they want any chance in the
playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports